ideas alone are not enough you are a
genius you have tons of great ideas but
lots of people die geniuses with their
ideas never realized it's not enough to
know you need to do the world belongs to
those who take action and execute
[Music]
I know I want to be in show business and
I just happened to luck out and things
happen I think you know it yeah you know
you if you you know what you're supposed
to do
keep down this I think everybody does
and a lot of people just don't go after
it you know like most people start out
this way I want to be as this but I'm
gonna give that to make sure I have
something to fall back on and what
you're doing is you setting yourself up
a fake cuz you're going and there's a
possibility to fall back and when you
put that out there then you fall back
but if you just say hey this is what I
want to do and you go do it you usually
get your stuff the way you wanted man
it's very easy for people who are in the
beginning levels of success or the
beginning levels of their success
journey to tell themself stories that
other people's circumstances are better
than theirs that the other people have
rich parents that got luck they've got
better circumstances they've got less
obstacles they tell themselves over and
over and over again as to why they can't
move forward and other people can why if
they do the work it still isn't going to
work out
[Music]
and what ends up happening is is that
they end up going through their life
something what they're dealt doing what
they're told and they end up at fifty
sixty years old
wondering what happened why me what am I
supposed to do now am I supposed to feel
better than I'm not the only one losing
my job and this is the way you treat me
how you sleep at night there well I'm
gonna tell you what happened
you talked yourself out of going after
what you were supposed to go after you
talked yourself out of your purpose I
have enough guts to go out there and try
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger to practice one thing that
makes them great is they are willing to
sacrifice I mean yes they're passionate
but did you know the root of the word
passion is suffering you've got to be
willing to suffer for your vision you've
got to be willing to suffer to reach BIW
best in world you've got to be willing
to suffer the ridicule and laughter of
your critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class the way of the
entrepreneur is is actually about going
looking at the world and finding
problems
[Music]
some people think that's a negative
mindset but actually I find it is like
it's a it's a curious mindset is you're
out there looking for problems looking
for things that aren't the way they
should be or could be
[Music]
ideas can make much more money than
actual physical labor and physical labor
is always part of the action now we have
a great idea but then you still have to
implement it but then normally if it is
just physical labor you can never make
the money then you can make many of
ideas so this is why it's important to
really think and they really have to get
creative and have a clear vision of
where you want to go and what you want
to do and that's what I always had this
what I always believe they know I think
we've all observed a lot of people who
they love reading the books they love
showing up at the courses they do all
the online training and nothing ever
changes and they say well you know I
don't know why it doesn't change why my
life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
everybody's got ideas doing the ideas we
all have here we could probably sit here
for the next two hours draw them all out
record them and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years
and 5% of the challenge is a strategy
95% of the execution this I said it as
CEO of Nissan I said it also a CEO of
Renault and our strategies finds very
important but it's only 5%
if you don't go to execution after this
the delivery and the performance of the
company is going to be very weak I
really I really believe it now it
doesn't mean strategy's not important
but when you establish north and you
know exactly where north is for the
company you've done something very
important because you're giving the
direction but if you don't start moving
north if you don't start mapping and
establishing milestone
you never you're never gonna be getting
there you're never gonna be getting
there okay everybody has an idea not
every has a good idea but people have
good ideas Laura uber is a good idea you
push a button and get a ride I don't
know if we were the first person ever
think of that
idea but we were the first person to do
it whoever was magic cab three years
earlier
uber is not an idea we're existent it's
called magic cab but the guys that
executed sucked so they lost so I think
you know if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea I'd
like to suffocate it because I think the
actual situation is what you actually do
with it none of us but at least most of
us are not the smartest people in the
world there are lots and lots of great
great inventors out there how are we
going to be the person who's going to
always build a better mousetrap the
business always comes down to block and
tackle it's not about the great vision
it's always about the great execution
and you can always succeed by out
executing your competitors not
necessarily having the best product in
the marketplace and I think the
Microsoft is a great example where they
took a same product that other people
may have had but they executed
substantially better and today the
market leader in the industry
this is the wall that franca and I built
in 1971 remember we gave them a lifetime
guarantee so I see some problems up with
right oh yeah remember 1974 up on the
first apartment building and we bought
it for two hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars but it's it was then a lot of
money yep
and I put on it down like maybe thirty
five thirty seven thousand dollars but
we did two years the apartment building
was worthless over two hundred fifteen
three hundred and fifty thousand
thousand and a sword
it's imagine now how much gain there was
yeah I mean so we made hundreds of
percent of my initial investment so
that's what I'm talking about any of you
guys heard of the media temple grid
server solution that was my idea
year or two before it came out and I
spent a million bucks on it and it
failed miserably because we never
launched anything and if you can't move
fast enough
someone like media tumbles gonna beat
you to the punch get a ton of customers
and make a lot of money
make a plan work the plan make a plan
work the plan and whenever the plan
doesn't work you change the plan that's
called failure it's called learning the
lessons called adjusting on the run you
are not going to have a perfect plan
from start to finish just because you
thought of an idea
[Music]
perfection is overrated nothing's ever
perfect you're gonna continue to have to
iterate so forth so on it's never gonna
be perfect there's always gonna be
issues just get it out there and start
trying to make money you need to be very
flexible on the details because as you
go along pursuing your vision you'll
find that some of your preconceptions
were wrong and you're gonna need to be
able to change those things you have to
set deadlines people have to be held
accountable to them as well right can if
they're like milestones goals are too
big for those deadlines they're not
gonna get met so make them really small
and tangible that way you can see it
really well in advance if they're
actually gonna be met or not but what if
I do all this work and it doesn't work
what if I put in all this time to become
an excellent employee I don't get
promoted what if I put in all this work
to become an excellent salesman and I
don't sell what if what if what if and
I'll tell you what if what if you don't
douche where are you gonna be this is
gonna be any better than where you are
now I believe in making $1 the two and
having a good time way to pay my taxes
thank you video 15 million dollars and
taxes I say yes
that made a lot of money thank you guys
so much for watching another episode of
believe films this has been a super fun
project to put together it's a new
territory that I'm diving into for the
YouTube channel and I would love love
love love love to get your feedback what
did you think about this video what do
you think about the first video that we
put up about work ethic any thoughts
suggestions room for improvement that
come to mind please let me know please
share it with your friends
it's a again exciting project that I'm
working on and I want and they will have
I make it better thank you guys again so
so so much I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details